[Music]
this week on q a
musician and lecturer daryl davis
for over 30 years mr davis has
befriended members of the ku klux klan
to try to understand their hatred and to
convince them to change their ways
[Music]
daryl davis what impact did chuck berry
have on your life
chuck berry had a very profound impact
on me
the man was a genius
you know many people can say that they
wrote a song maybe people can say that
they played a song but few people can
claim that they invented a genre of
music
and chuck berry certainly did that we
would not have rock and roll without
chuck berry
and when i first heard chuck berry i
fell in love with that music and when i
saw him i changed my whole career
trajectory that i was on as a kid i was
going to be a computer programmer back
then computers were of course as big as
twice as big as this room
or a espionage agent
and each one was pulling at me with
equal force so i was immobilized could
move either way and i kept trying to
figure out
you know how can i do both and back then
of course there was no way today you can
through cyber espionage
but i saw chuck berry somewhere along
that pathway
as a kid and i said
that's what i want to do and what it was
was that chuck berry
another fellow elvis presley i'd seen
him too
had made millions upon millions of
people all over the world happy with
their music they touched them without
even knowing them
and that fascinated me i said you know
what that's what i want to do i want to
be able to bring joy to people whether i
ever meet them or not
what was the story about your first
meeting with chuck berry
well chuck berry was coming to coalfield
house at university of maryland the
sports arena there it was going to be
chuck berry and jerry lee lewis
and of course i got down there super
early hoping i would you know be able to
sneak in and maybe meet him during sound
checker rehearsal
and because i knew that the promoter had
to supply
a backing band for him
so the concert
would not begin till like about 8 p.m
that evening and i was a kid i got a
ride down there
and um
around noon time
you know like eight hours before
showtime
and the hangar doors were open people
were like bringing in equipment and
speakers and lights and things like that
i just walked on in nobody stopped me um
so i said you know there was no security
there at that particular time
and so i just hung out back there stood
out of everybody's way
uh the band came
and i moved over near the stage where
the band was figuring that when chuck
comes for this sound check you know i'll
get to see my idol and meet him or
whatever
and the band was very nervous
they'd never worked with chuck berry
before they were down from new jersey to
uh to play for him
and their sound check was at two o'clock
so they assumed that he would be there
around two o'clock well two o'clock
rolled around and no chip berry
and they even got more nervous and so
they went on stage they did their sound
check they ran through some chuck berry
songs and they sounded fantastic
and you know the hours ticked by and
still know chuck berry
and so um
they went on at the you know at the
beginning of the year show you know did
a short set
and then
uh jerry lee lewis you know came and i
got to meet him
and he came on and did his thing still
no chuck berry and about
about 15 minutes or so before
jerry lee finished in walked chuck berry
through the backstage door he came in
just by himself no guitar nothing
and he walked right by me
and i froze i thought oh you know you
know it was like a total shock
he went right by me and there was
somebody standing down the hallway
and he stopped and spoke with that
person i don't know what he said but in
retrospect i do that person pointed
further down the hallway to a door
and chuck you know went down and went
inside that door
and a few minutes later he came back out
went right back by me again back outside
the backstage door and then he returned
with his guitar
and so in retrospect what happened was
he went down to the promoter's office to
get paid up front
and then he went and got his guitar and
he doesn't bring his guitar until he
until he has money
so um brought his guitar in
and then you know i'm standing over
there near where the band was he came
over
and um
the band leader walked up to him he's
like taking his guitar out of the case
and said hi you know my name is bruce
springsteen we are you know we're your
backup band we thought you were going to
be here this afternoon jesse no no just
totally oblivious and um you said uh
we ran through some of your songs i
think everything should be okay do you
know which ones you know you're gonna
play tonight
and chuck said something to the effect
of i think i'll play some chuck berry
and he went on stage the ben went on
right after him and he just like went
right into it no key no count off
nothing and the band was right there
with them and that just kind of like
just blew my mind now you slipped in the
word the name bruce springsteen right
what time what year was this this is
like
1972-73
somewhere around there april of 72 or
73. you guys went 15 uh yeah
uh i was born in 58. anybody ever heard
of bruce springsteen at the time no one
had ever had ever heard of bruce
springsteen outside of asbury park new
jersey you know and so the name didn't
mean anything you know to me
and then like i don't know a year or so
later he's on the cover of time magazine
you know
and uh so it's like wow you know that's
that same that's the same guy i want to
show some video then that was like in
the early 70s this is in 1997.
if people look closely they'll see you
at the piano so let's watch this clip
okay
[Music]
waiting for them
[Music]
how did you end up on that stage
that's a really funny story
it was a late night with david letterman
and i knew chuck was going to be on
there
and i called him and i said hey you know
um
i'm going to come up to new york and
hang out with you and he said all right
so um i i took the train or the bus up
to new york and um i went i went to the
studio where that thing is taped and he
had my name on the guest list you know
at the uh backstage where security was
uh he wasn't there yet
so uh they let me in
and they said mr berry is not here yet
but you're welcome to either go to his
dressing room or go in the green room so
i stopped by the green room tony randall
was in there and rosanna barr
and a couple other people
uh who else are going to be on the show
david does um like two separate tapings
per night
and so then i went up to the to the
green room i mean going to uh chuck's
dressing room and eventually he came and
we're just sitting there and then this
producer walks in
and um says hi mr berry my name is
whatever and uh
you know i have you slated to uh to do
um
uh rollover beethoven with uh paul
schaefer and his band
and chuck said
this is my piano player daryl davis and
she started flipping through pages on
her clipboard
looking for my name she goes oh i i
didn't know uh your piano player was
going to be here we have uh paul
schaefer slated here
and he says this is my piano player
daryl davis daryl give her your social
security number so you can get paid i
had not even planned on playing you know
i just came to hang out
i'm like oh goodness you know so i gave
her my social because i'm also a member
of after and sag and all that and
musicians union and so she's like all
flustered
she said well okay um i i will uh talk
to mr schaefer and um and then you all
are gonna perform rollover beethoven
and chuck said no i think i'll do let it
rock
she's like huh you know you're totally
you know lost
and she says well uh mr schaefer has
been rehearsing the the group with uh
wilder beethoven just said uh like i
said i i think i would do let it rock uh
daryl go on down there and and rehearse
the band
so i went down there and there was paul
shaffer and paul schaefer is
not only one of the most talented
musicians in this country he's totally
underrated the guy is a genius
a just a top-notch musician
not only is he one of the most talented
musicians in this country he is also one
of the nicest and most humblest
and he had no problem with it whatsoever
and i rehearsed the band on let it rock
and then he asked me he said hey you
know would you like to stay up here you
know through the commercials and stuff
and play with us you know until chuck
comes on and play with him and he comes
on i said thank you for the invitation
about this time our regular viewers are
saying what in the world
are they talking about there they we
don't normally talk music on the show
and there's a lot more to this story
than the music but i want to go back to
how did you develop a relationship with
chuck berry and then what impact did he
have on
your thinking about the humanity and
race relations and things like that in
this country well you know
people like chuck berry elvis presley
little richard jerry lee lewis fats
domino buddy holly bo diddly
you know these people were the pioneers
of rock and roll
back in the day
prior to rock and roll
music halls
concert venues
were segregated if they allowed black
people in at all
you know there were ropes going around
the seating sections with signs hanging
that would say seating for white patrons
only or colored seating only and that
jim crow law was still in place in the
1950s so you know if if you and i you
know we're going to go see glenn miller
or somebody sinatra in the 40s we could
not sit together
we have to sit in our designated seating
sessions according to the color of our
skin so even in the 1950s that law was
in place but two phenomenons happened
one
the invention of rock and roll by people
like chuck berry little richard
fass domino bo diddley and the
popularization of it by people like
elvis presley jerry lee lewis carl
perkins buddy ollie bill haley in the
comets
when white kids
and black kids heard that new
rhythm that new beat that boogie woogie
with a back beat to it
they could not sit still
they bounced up out of their chairs
knocked the ropes over and the signs
over and next thing you know they were
boogieing and dancing in the aisles
together for the first time in the
history of this country police would
come in shut down the show
so rock and roll had brought white youth
and black youth together
through music
the same thing
that great civil rights activists like
martin the king and rosa parks and many
other ones black and white were trying
to achieve
through their marches through their
demonstrations their sit-ins their
boycotts in efforts to bring
white and black adults together
chuck berry and elvis were achieving
this through music
and that attracted me as well how long
have you been a musician
professionally
well since i graduated college in 1980
where'd you graduate from from howard
university in washington dc with my
degree in jazz but you know i was
playing slightly before that you know
during college you know during my
formative learning years i was kind of a
late bloomer when it came to music i
started when i was
17 in high school a junior
i want to jump
way out of context there is a new
documentary
about you on netflix and it's called
accidental courtesy you've gotten a lot
of publicity over the years for the
things that you've been involved in but
let's just run a brief clip of this and
then i'll ask you to fill in the blanks
sure
there's a robe of an imperial wizard the
top guy this is a white cotton robe
with blue adornments blue stripes blue
sash and blue cape and of course you see
the clan emblem the my oak the red blood
drop in the center signifies that they
will shed their blood to preserve the
white race
if you look along the white cross
look at that that black line right there
and then these two diagonal lines they
form a k
so you see four k's essentially and that
stands for
knights of the ku klux klan
people always say to me darrell how can
you have this stuff why don't you burn
it
well no as shameful as it is
this is a part of american history you
don't burn our history regardless the
good the bad the ugly and the ku klux
klan
is as american as baseball apple pie and
chevrolet what's the story behind the
documentary
well and
a book on me came out that i wrote in
1997 in hardback and paperback in 1998
called clandestine spell with a k
relationships clandestine relationships
in which i went around the country and
interviewed plan leaders and clan
members
based on an experience i had as a child
when i was a kid
i had a racist incident while marching
with the cub scouts i had people
throwing rocks and bottles at me you
know white spectators
and i did not understand why i was a
target
and then when racism was explained to me
i could not accept it i'd never heard of
racism and i could not get my head
around the idea that someone who had
never spoken to me someone who knew
nothing about me or had ever seen me
before would want to hurt me
for no other reason than the color of my
skin and i formed a question
at the age of 10 in 1968 which was how
can you hate me when you don't even know
me
and i've been seeking that answer now
for the next you know 49 years
and i bought books on black supremacy
white supremacy the nazis in germany the
neo-nazis over here the ku klux klan
looking for the answer in these books
and i couldn't find it so in my adult
life i figured well
who better to ask
than someone who would join an
organization
that is reputed to believe
that somebody else is inferior to who
does not look like them or believe as
they believe based on the color of their
skin or their religious beliefs
so i decided i would seek out clan
members
and ask them to answer the question and
then i would get my answer
so the book
came out of course a lot of publicity
came behind that my book is the first
book by a black author on the ku klux
klan with face-to-face in-person
interviews
so that generated publicity
and some you know different producers of
documentaries and things like that began
contacting me you know wanting to uh to
do a documentary on this work
and so years later after sifting through
a lot of them
we decided on on these particular
producers
and thus was the product the product
accidental courtesy of what you just
showed a clip
who was the first member of the ku klux
klan that you met and how did you do it
well the first one that i ever met
was a pretty negative encounter um
it ended up in violence but the first
one that i met to sit down and interview
he was the leader
of the ku klux klan the state of
maryland now a state leader is what's
known as a grand dragon which we would
call a governor oversees the entire
state
uh and then the the top guy the national
guy who oversees all the states
which we would call a president that
person is known as the imperial wizard
so the grand dragon his name was roger
kelly and he went from grand dragon
eventually to imperial wizard he was the
first one that i met and sat down with
and had a conversation how did you set
it up
well i had my secretary my secretary was
white
and not that i care but i mention it
because it's very important to the story
i had acquired roger kelly's personal
address and phone number
and i gave it to her and the person who
gave it to me warned me daryl do not
fool with mr kelly you know you get
yourself killed and
i wanted to sit him down and talk to him
so that was not going to deter me but i
wanted to make it
um so i didn't jinx myself
i had my secretary call him
and i figured you know
if i called him he might pick up in my
voice and i'm black
i'm not talking to you click and then my
whole project would have ended before it
ever got started so i knew
that if she called him
he would just automatically know from
her voice that you know this is a white
lady and he would not automatically
assume that this white woman was working
for
a black man especially a black man who's
writing a book on the klan because they
didn't exist you know at the time
so uh
she called him and i i had told her
do not tell him
that i'm black unless he asked if he
asked and don't lie to him but don't
allude to it don't give him reason to
ask because if he if he agrees to do it
you know he'll figure that out when he
sees me and then he can make up his mind
right then and there if he wants to talk
to me or not because you know i figured
i
if i'm going to meet him i want to be
spontaneous i didn't want him to have if
he agreed knowing that i was black i
didn't want him to have different
answers for a white interviewer than he
would have for a black interviewer so
she called and she spoke with him and he
agreed to meet with me and didn't ask
what color i was what was his reaction
well we uh we had it set up for a motel
room
and uh when when he showed up we were
already in the room
and
we had i had a bucket of ice with cans
of soda there so i could be hospitable
and offer him a beverage well he showed
up with his bodyguard which is called a
grand nighthawk a grand nighthawk is a
bodyguard to the grand dragon like a
granny uh like an imperial nighthawk
will be the bodyguard for the imperial
wizard so this grand nighthawk walked
into the room first
and he was wearing military camouflage
uh fatigues with the mayo the blood drop
emblem right here
and the initials kkk right here on his
chest
embroidered across his beret on his head
were knights of the ku klux klan and on
his hip he had a semi-automatic handgun
in a holster
he came in and he was followed
right behind him by uh by mr kelly the
grand dragon and a dark blue suit and
tie
when the nighthawk entered the room and
turned the corner
and saw me he just
froze
and mr kelly bumped into his back
because the guy stopped short and they
stumbled and regained their balance
looking all around the room
and i knew what they were thinking they
were thinking you know either the desk
clerk you know gave them the wrong room
number or this was a setup this is an
ambush
so i went like this
to display my hands nothing in them and
i stood up and i approached him i said
hi mr kelly my name is daryl davis come
on in
he both he and the nighthawk shook my
hand so far so good and they both came
in
and then what well i asked him to have a
seat
he sat down he asked me for some
identification
and i gave that to him
and then we proceeded with this
interview now i had a bag beside me and
in my bag
i had a copy of the bible
because the ku klux klan claims to be a
christian organization and they also
claim that the bible preaches
racial separation
now in my reading of the bible i'd never
seen that in there so i wanted to be
able to pull out my bible and say here
please show me chapter and verse where
it says blacks and whites must be
separate i also had blank cassettes in
the bag because i had a cassette player
sitting in the middle of the table to
record my
interview well we you know we began
you're talking back and forth uh he let
me know that um
i was inferior because i was black
and um you know say why yeah because
black people have smaller brains
and um
we're basically uh inclined to be lazy
and uneducated and things like that you
know all the stereotypes but when it
came out physical reaction to that
sending having him sitting across from
me well it's interesting because when he
was sitting across from me he was
wearing a suit and tie
and you know i know who i am and i'm
confident in who i am so that wasn't
gonna you know throw me
um
and i was expecting stuff like that
because you know i read all these books
on the clan already so i knew the
mentality
but i wanted to draw everything out of
him to find out
you know how can he hate me when he
doesn't even know me and hasn't even
given me a chance to express myself and
see if he still has those feelings what
happened to that relationship
we became you know the best of friends
the best friends the best of friends
eventually what does that mean it means
we would hang out we would go out to
dinner um you know not not all the next
day or the next week but over time you
know there was an incident that happened
in the room
that uh
that was a teaching moment i won't say
it was a learning moment
you know that would come later
but
every time i would reach down to pull
out a fresh cassette or pull up the
bible because he made some biblical
reference whenever i reached down the
nighthawk would reach up to his gun
because he didn't know was in that bag
and you know understandably so
eventually he realized there was no
threat in the bag and he relaxed and i
went in and out of the bag no problem
a little later on in the interview there
was kind of a strange noise in the room
and we all jumped
and i just knew that mr kelly had made
the noise because i didn't make it and
because i could not discern what the
noise was
i perceived it to be ominous and
threatening
and plus i was hearing that voice in my
head daryl don't fool with roger kelly
he'll kill you kind of thing
and
i was ready to attack
you know my eyes had locked with his
eyes
because i'm looking at him like what did
you just do i didn't say that but my
eyes were speaking to him his eyes had
locked with mine
and i could read the expression in his
eyes which were saying to me what did
you just do
and the nighthawk had his hand on his
gun looking back and forth between the
two of us like what did either one of
you all just do
well my secretary
was over to my left sitting on top of
the dresser because there were no more
chairs there
and she realized what had happened the
ice in the bucket had melted
and the cans of soda shifted and that's
what made the noise and then we all
began laughing
at how ignorant we all had been but the
teaching moment was this
all because
some foreign and underscore highlight
the word foreign
entity of which we were ignorant that
being the bucket of ice and cans of soda
entered into our little comfort zone
via the noise that it made we became
fearful and accusatory of one another so
the lesson learned is ignorance breeds
fear
if you don't keep that fear in check
that fear will breed hatred because we
hate those things that frighten us
if you don't keep that hatred in check
that hatred will breed destruction
from the documentary accidental courtesy
um can you buy this too if you can't if
you don't have netflix yes you can buy
you can order it from the from the
company or itunes netflix here's
somebody that kicked back at you
uh somebody of your own race let's watch
this and
tell us all about sure
without wasting your time going into
people's houses that don't love you a
house where they want to throw you under
the basement so you believe that nobody
can change
no you i believe you believe the wrong
people can change
what do you mean the wrong people don't
trust right supremacists can't change
you don't believe they can change
no white supremacists can't change but i
can change your mind cause you look like
me
you ain't doing nothing but collecting
something that's gonna build your own
credibility you nothing but a pimp in a
pulpit
and you're nothing but ignorant
who was that where was that done that
was done in baltimore
and that guy is my friend now his name
is kwame rose
he is an activist with uh black lives
matter
and that was done
oh roughly a little
about it about a year and a couple
months ago
and kwame rose another gentleman who was
also there you didn't see in the clip uh
we had dinner together
about a month ago
and all those differences have been
resolved he was he was not
um fully aware of what i do and how i do
it he had received bad information prior
to to that
scene right there i had met him outside
the bar
uh where where that scene took place
and the first thing he said to me was
upon our very first meeting of seeing
each other was
i understand you're the first black
member of the kkk
so that right there you know
was his mindset
and of course you know if there were
black members of the kkk they wouldn't
be a kkk
so
he had bad information
and he was acting upon that without
giving the back story and now that he
and i have gotten together and talked
we are we are friends and we have agreed
to work together to fight this this
disease called racism
what kind of a family did you grow up in
uh my parents were us foreign service
so i spent a lot of time you know
overseas
in various countries around the world
uh with you know as an american embassy
brat
and today as a professional musician i
travel all over this country and around
the world if you combine my travels as a
child with now my travels as an adult
i've been in 53 different countries on
six continents
what difference do you think it made for
you that you saw other worlds
you know it made a world i mean not to
use a plan here but it made a world of
difference
because i was exposed
early on
to many many different cultures
ethnicities nationalities traditions
colors religions etc and all of that
helped shape who i've become and i saw
people from all over the world
getting along with each other when i was
in grade school overseas you know i'd be
over there for two years and come back
home be here for a few months or a year
and then go back to another country
when i was a kid in this in the 1960s in
in elementary school
my classes were filled with other kids
from nigeria italy japan
russia france germany anybody who had an
embassy in those countries all of their
kids we all went to the same school and
that's how i grew up if you were to peep
your head into my classroom door you
would say that looks like a united
nations of little kids
that scenario was not here back here in
my own country in the u.s when i would
return i would either be in newly
integrated or still segregated schools
that had not quite gotten there yet so i
was either surrounded by all black
people or black and white people today
when you walk into
a a school classroom you see what i saw
but back then i was living 12 to 15
years ahead of my time
more from accidental
courtesy this is another uh discussion
you're having about a man named robert
white
it's about 35 seconds
robert white
got busted for assault attempted murder
two black men with a shotgun
he went on to become
a very good friend of mine we going to
my wedding sure i'll be at your wedding
if you won't be there why would you why
would you go to his wedding if you don't
believe in the mixing of races i will
attend a wedding if he wants me there
just because he's sterile as a result of
our friendship he left the plan
this is his clan road his grand dragon
robe
his day job
was this
this is his jacket baltimore city police
officer
where is he today
robert white has since passed
how long ago
in 2007. how did he become your friend
well he was in prison when i first
contacted him i wanted to interview him
for my book
and we had a correspondence you know
back and forth not knowing that i was
black he was vehemently racist and
anti-semitic a very very vicious and
violent man
and
shortly before he got out of prison he
found out that i was black he had some
of his clan people on the outside come
check me out and report back to him and
he was all upset that i had not informed
him of the color of my skin and i said
what difference does it make you know
you said you're going to tell me the
truth you know when you get out and we
get together you know does the truth
differ when you talk to a white person
than to a black person so he said no he
agreed and so we got together
and as i said he was you know very angry
very violent very hateful
but we kept getting together time and
time and time again
and he began to see me
as a human being and over time he began
to shed that ideology but just to
address another point you know of my
growing up uh and traveling to these
different places and being exposed to
these things
one of my very favorite quotes of all
time
is
um
by mark twain it's called the travel
quote
and
mark twain says travel is fatal to
prejudice bigotry and narrow-mindedness
and many of our people need it sorely on
these accounts
broad wholesome charitable views of men
and things cannot be acquired by
vegetating in one little corner of the
earth all one's lifetime
who is the fellow sitting at the table
with you in that video
that gentleman was a former baltimore
city police officer
and you know the baltimore city police
department has been
saturated with racist police officers
and ku klux klan members such as bob
white and the other ones that he's told
me about himself
how big is a ku klux klan in the united
states today
you know no one really knows for sure
um you know the mentality is certainly
very large in terms of just the clan
itself clan members as opposed to you
know every white supremacists and
different organizations
i think the the adl and the southern
poverty law center estimate between 5
000 8 000 members if you go back to the
early nineteen twenties the numbers are
four million yes three million alone in
indiana it goes right down the list to
you know over the years is it more less
and less of the ku klux klan why has it
lessened in membership
it is nothing in membership because
people evolve
and you know they they begin to
appreciate one another when they come in
contact with one another
um
but it has its ebbs and flows
you know it rises it falls it rises it
falls
and a lot of people
while they want to be they don't want to
be associated with let's say with blacks
and jews
um they don't also want to be associated
with the violence that the klan brings
either for moral reasons or for legal
reasons so you know they'll drop out and
join some other uh racist group
like um the white citizens council
you know which uh is more political they
put people in uh positions of leadership
you know in order to institutionalize
those racist beliefs did you ask anybody
to let you go to a meeting of the kkk
absolutely and i was invited to meetings
in fact yeah i would go to meetings and
and plan rallies and see these things
and document them for my book
um
in fact about just over a month ago
the tennessee and kentucky chapters of
the clan invited me down there to come
to one of their meetings and speak to
them did you i absolutely did absolutely
what did you tell them
i told them a lot you told them about
you know what i felt about what happened
recently in charlottesville
and and some of the other things you
know that i felt their perspectives were
skewed and they sat and listened and
then i did a q a at the end and some
asked me questions and then we all went
out and had lunch
together
you mentioned earlier that your first
meeting was a member of the kkk was
violent yes can you tell us that story
well i just finished a gig
a musical performance
and i was going across this parking lot
to get something to eat at this all
night you know restaurant
your greasy spoon or whatever you want
to call it
and as i pulled into my parking space i
saw a man
straddled across a woman on the sidewalk
he was sitting on her and he was banging
her head into the sidewalk and hitting
her in the face
and you know i was shocked and i pulled
in my space
and and i was gonna go over there and
pull him off and when i got out of the
car he was oblivious to me he was just
going at it and i just pulled in you
know two spaces away from him and when i
got out of the car and closed my door
he like jumped up and looked at me
and he said
what are you looking at [ __ ]
and to me that was open invitation
and i said i'm looking at you and he got
up off of her and he came and he
attacked me
and i had to put him down i had to hurt
him and put him down
and um
the police now people were standing
around watching this
and doing nothing about it nothing
they did not call the police
these were white people
watching this white man beat up this
white woman
they did not call the police until this
black man beat up the white guy
then they called the police well these
two officers came
and something was very strange
they would not arrest the guy
because i wanted him arrested for
assault
and they would not arrest him
um they told him however to leave the uh
the premises and if he were to set foot
back on this property within 24 hours he
would be arrested for
trespassing and i said well i want him
arrested now when he left
and they said well you'll have to go
fill out a warrant or whatever else at
the police station i said okay so i went
inside i got some ice for this lady i
applied it to the back of her head and
helped her and i asked her i said you
know i'm going to have him arrested you
know you know not only for assaulting me
but what he did to you etc you know
would you i'm happy to come to court you
know if you want to press charges
against him you know would you be
willing testify on my behalf and she
said yes she gave me her phone number
and her address and stuff
so i helped her fix up her head i went
down to the police station
and the commissioner gave me this you
know thing to fill out and i'm filling
out my complaint
and i asked him i said um now these were
county cops
who came to to respond
um i asked him i said how long will it
take before this guy is served because i
made the police give me his information
which they did
so
the commission said uh well it goes from
here to the uh sheriff's and they
dispatch a deputy maybe three days
i said okay
and so i'm filling it out and in walks
the guy
the guy that i beat up
and he walks into the police station
with two
state police officers on either side of
him and he's in handcuffs i said well
that's him right there that's him right
there
and the commissioner said well sign you
know sign it and i will serve him right
now so i signed it the commissioner
ticket rolled it up took off a copy
rolled it up and walked out there and
stuck it in between the guy's arms
because he was handcuffed like this
and so um i found out later on what
happened was this when the two original
cops the county cops left
because he left first because he told
him to leave
he came back
looking for me
to finish the fight i wasn't there i'm
down the police station he goes inside
the restaurant
and picks a fight with some other black
guy
and so this time the state police
responded
and they were having none of that
and they locked him up what happened to
him eventually well what i come to find
out is from his from this woman she was
his ex-fiancee she had left him because
he was seeing somebody else who he had
gotten pregnant
and and he was like if well if i can't
have you nobody will bam bam bam so she
tells me
that he is a
high-ranking official on the county fire
department and he's a member of the ku
klux klan so i beat up a klansman he's a
fireman which explained to me why the
two county police officers did not
arrest them they knew each other should
i assume that you did not become friends
with this clansman oh yes you can assume
that yes back to the
back
to your relationship with a man named
frank and connor let's watch
yes
let's watch this
clan
and our constitution you know says we we
want to maintain white supremacy in
america you don't see the the pearl and
the eagle don't fly together they're
both they're both birds
but he said that they don't mix together
i mean that's one of the reasons we
should have all of our own our own
nations
when it comes to race you know everybody
thinks the klan's a hate organization i
mean don't you have churches that only
cater to blacks though yeah because we
couldn't get into the white churches
[Laughter]
badminton forward march
classman oh
right face
for my god
oh my god
for my country
much
do they really believe
in that kind of a ceremony
a lot of them do believe that very
heavily you know they are inundated and
initiated with a ceremony and it makes
them feel like they belong to something
it's it's a fraternity you know it's
it's not a fraternity that the uri would
join
but it's it's a it's a a fraternity
where each of one has each other's back
and um they they strongly believe in
that you brought uh
some of your possessions with you i did
uh hold that up if you would please so
we can see what it is and you did
explain that earlier but how did you get
the hold of the okay this is a grand
dragon's robe which means state leader
and you have your choice of a white
cotton robe
um
with uh green is the color for the grand
level with green stripes
a green cape
and a green satch again this is the
blood drop emblem or the my oak that all
clan members use here he has a dragon
patch signifying his rank
under the cape
you see another dragon patch
you also
could have
a green full grain satin robe again
that's
personal choice cotton or satin if it's
a cotton it'd be white with a different
color adornments if it's satin the whole
thing would be that color did you have
to buy those by the way did i buy them
no they were given to me by klansmen
they were given to me by active clan
members who left the organization what's
the next one this is the robe of an
imperial wizard okay this is the top guy
and uh blue or purple your choice
designates the imperial level again this
is a white cotton robe with blue
adornments
can you buy those online
that i don't know
i i doubt it
unless somebody is you know selling one
who has one what's the last one there
the green one is that the one you were
just talking about yeah okay here this
green one here is
another grand dragon's robe this one
belonged to bob white
the gentleman that we were talking about
in the accidental courtesy clip that you
showed the baltimore city police officer
and
he was put he was imprisoned
for four years for conspiring to bomb a
synagogue in baltimore as a police
officer as a police officer right then
um he got put off the way he was forced
to resign from the police department
because he was he was bringing
embarrassment to them they knew who he
was and they knew what he was doing but
as long as he did not uh bring you know
any uh repercussions to them they turned
a blind eye to it and there were others
on that force okay so here's his robe
and
he preferred the satin so a full green
satin rope but there's no difference
between that one and the cotton one
here is his
baltimore city police uniform
and how long ago was he a baltimore
policeman this is that back in the 1970s
where is he now
he's deceased now
i want to go back to frank
and kona yes i want to show you some
video
from cbs news this year in february and
then talk about this gentleman after
they see this sure
in missouri a ku klux klan leader is
shot and killed in his bedroom and
officials say his own family was behind
the murder frank and kona's body was
found saturday about 20 miles from his
home he had been shot in the head
prosecutors say his klan membership was
not a factor in the killing but rather
that the motive was more personal they
say ancona told his wife he wanted a
divorce melissa ancona and her son paul
jenkerson are charged with first degree
murder tampering with evidence and
abandonment of a corpse investigators
say jiggerson was the one who pulled the
trigger and that melissa helped clean up
the scene both are being held without
bail how good a friend had he become of
yours frank and kona had become a very
very good friend i had been in in his
home several times i knew
uh his wife uh melissa what happened to
her after all this and well she's in
jail right now and she is blaming the
sun and the sun is blaming her
and in fact
frank and kona and i
were such good friends
all right you know i i would say if he
was still alive
within a year's time he would have been
out of the clan
and and he would have given me his robe
okay today i do own his robe but i'll
get to that in a second
um
i knew
what had happened
to my friend frank ancona before the
police did why believe it or not all
right i was sitting at a friend of
mine's house
going through some video
and he's like a little video editor
and i got a call
just after midnight
and it was from a klansman
and he said daryl um
i believe frank has gone missing
and i said what do you mean
and he wanted to say that frank had not
gone to work he was not home
and he thought there was some something
odd going on
and because you know frank you know and
melissa were kind of at odds now frank
loved his wife i can tell you that he
generally loved his wife he was a
courier he would drive across state
delivering different things and
oftentimes he would call me on the phone
while he's in his car by himself just to
you know check on me or keep or for me
to keep him company while he's driving
and um
i knew he loved her but he was having a
lot of issues with her because she was
an
opioid addict
and a methamphetamine addict
so um he was considering leaving her
and um
anyway this guy tells me that he thinks
melissa has something to do with it
and i said oh you know maybe he just you
know went somewhere you know just to
cool down or whatever he goes i don't
think so daryl so then he says he was
gonna dig a little further because he
said he had talked to melissa and her
story wasn't quite adding up she kept
you know being ambiguous so he said he
would talk to her some more he called me
back
around four o'clock in the morning
and told me
frank is dead
and he had talked to the wife
and she told him what happened and what
had gone on
she confessed to him
and he told me
and this was before it wasn't until
about maybe three days later that the
police
found out what happened
you know just listening to your uh
talk here in the last 45 minutes or so
you get the impression that every time
you come in contact with a klans member
you become friends not every time you
know tell me what happens when you don't
become friends
well you don't become friends no but i
mean what is the dialogue back and forth
and how do you know that you're not
getting through because you know well
you have people who are ignorant and you
have people who are stupid and you know
we all are ignorant to a certain degree
because we don't know everything
but an ignorant person is someone who
can learn
you you give me the facts you give me
the proper information you have
alleviated my ignorance and i can apply
that to make the right decision or a
good choice
but if i'm stupid i have the facts but i
still make the wrong choice so i'm well
aware that there are people who will go
to their graves being hateful violent
and racist there is no change in them
whatsoever and i've met some of those
people
and they are very dangerous people and
they are unchangeable
most of them are dangerous and i won't
say all of them are but uh you know
they're just so skewed
no amount of facts or anything is going
to change their belief do you have a
family
i i have a wife yes and i have children
not of my own step children but they're
grown
where do you live now i live in silver
spring maryland how much of your time is
spent on this versus your jazz piano
work oh rock and roll jazz blues country
um
i would say
between 50 50 60 40.
what's happened with all the publicity
you've gotten what impacts that had on
you
it's interesting because
that third i've been doing this for 30
years
and when i first started doing this
people thought you know you're crazy
and you know i i was called a kook and
this and the other and
i'm gonna get myself killed and
even some people
began shunning me
today black folks are white from both
both you know because i'd gone off my
rocker or something
today some of these same people
are calling me up saying daryl
what do we do you know these people what
do we do
because you know racism has become so
emboldened today
you know now people are beginning to
take notice of it whereby before either
they were in denial or living in their
little bubble it was not affecting them
but now it's out there in your face and
now they don't know what to do so they
go to somebody who's been you know
embedded with it for a while
president trump calls you up and says
come to the oval office
you you got an hour with him what would
you start telling him
about this issue
and what would you like just to tell him
from what you've seen over the last
couple years in this camp in the
political world i would absolutely go
and and i would i would be very happy to
sit down with president trump and go
over this and i would ask him
to give me a position paid or unpaid
to help
um resolve many of the racial issues in
this country
and and personally you know
i believe president trump this is my
belief
is one of the best things that has
happened to this country
because all of this stuff is now coming
up to the surface i'm not saying that
was his plan or or his design
but as a result of his presidency all of
this stuff is coming up where before
there was a taboo on talking about
racism oh and we talked about that you
put under the carpet it's not
politically correct now we're having to
address it as in our face but
i've always seen it so you know it was
never hidden from me
but people are going about it the wrong
way to resolve it people are talking
about each other or they're talking at
each other
i sit down and talk with each other and
that's what results in my getting these
kinds of things
and i never set out to convert anybody
i set out to listen to them explain
their points of view what they fear what
they think and then i'm able to share
mine
and the in and that is impetus for them
to think and oftentimes they reconsider
that ideology which is how i get these
how much racism do you see in your
professional life when you're out there
playing that piano
i see it from time to time how what do
you see
there have been times well for example
the the moose lodge the moose lodge was
a very racist organization in this
country their bylaws forbid black people
to be in the moose lodge
so i was playing in a band one time
and i was not allowed to come in they
told the band that they had to bring a
white piano player and the band leader
said no where we go daryl goes
and so the moose lodge
rented an outside facility
just to have this band so i could play
okay now today of course the moose lodge
is
uh a black person was brought by a white
member
to be a guest and they and they refused
entrance so the black person sued the
moose lodge in federal court and and the
federal judge said if you don't change
that law i will shut down every muslim
in the country so that changed it let me
ask you this though if you're a black
person and the moose lodge doesn't you
know they had the rules that no black
people were like why would you want to
why would you even want to go there why
would you want to change it why would
you want to be involved with people that
would accept that kind of thing in their
bylaws
i'm not you know uh the muslim life
doesn't um
make me or break me i'm there to play
music and i know a lot of people don't
mean you i'm talking about the fella
that sued him why would he even care
about being a part of the most like
being a member
because this is our country
you know and we all should be treated
equally that's the whole thing with the
flag and the pledge of allegiance you
know
one nation indivisible you know under
god with liberty and justice for all
no it's not liberty and justice for all
so you know we our society is going to
be one of two things it's going to be
what we make it or it's going to be what
we let it become and i'd rather make it
equitable for everybody
you had a conversation um from an
accidental courtesy uh with a guy named
i don't know he pronounced it jeff
uh
i'm sorry scoop he bounces scoop yeah uh
a nationalist
national socialist movement commander i
i just want to go back to the way we
started on music and listen to this a
little bit of this conversation
you men and women that are here today if
we are going to take back this nation we
have to stand in solidarity white power
what kind of music do you like uh jeff
all kinds of music yeah rock
hardcore oy
rock against communism and do you
realize that rock was invented by black
musicians oh we're not going to go oh
yes we are oh yes we are yes my brother
we're going there
well who who invented rock then elvis
presley
you're not being serious right
what was that conversation like
um
very cordial very good yeah we exchanged
phone numbers
and you know jeff jeff is a hardcore
racist and supremacist still yes
why does he think that
the rock and roll music started with uh
elvis presley did you ever get through
that
um he knows where rock rock started but
he cannot bring himself
to admit that he likes something that
was invented by black people but however
uh if you know had you continued that
clip because i pointed out to him that
chuck berry invented rock and roll and
elvis presley popularized it all right
and then um and i i you know came down
on him for not accepting black
inventions and then he said that he
likes peanut butter
and black people invented peanut butter
and i said well who was it
and then he named you know george
washington carver
well you you have all this paraphernalia
how many of these robes do you have at
home
uh i don't keep them all at home i don't
keep a couple at home i keep i keep a
lot of them locked up off-site
but
i would guess you know i i got three
recently
and i would guess maybe i have between
40 42 44. and what how do you get them i
mean is that is that
is a decision made that you're going to
like each other and the guy says i'm
getting out of the clan and give it to
you
no actually um the first time i got one
the guy was going to get rid of it he
put it in a trash bag and was going to
throw it in a dumpster or something
and i said no no no let you know let me
have it
why would you want it
i said you know i just want it i didn't
know why i wanted it
but i i wanted it
and so i got it that way and then um
others when they decided to leave i said
you know what are you gonna do with your
stuff
and they're like you know i don't know
and i just get rid of it i said well you
know could i have it and they would give
it to me and now
i got people
um who know
you know clam people you know who've
heard about me or you know whatever
they've read articles see me on tv and
they know i have these robes and then
when they decide to leave or they've met
me they said you know would you like my
robe do you get invited to speak
i have i have uh i mean at a klan
meeting a rally i'm talking about to the
general public oh yes i do a lot of
speaking all over the country and abroad
what's been the impact of this
documentary on netflix accidental
courtesy
what's been the impact you know on the
country or netflix on you
well uh i think it has increased
uh speaking opportunities because you
know people now are very concerned and
need to address you know this issue you
know that they're confronted with in our
country especially since uh you know
charlottesville
so if somebody wants to hear you
play the piano
how do they find out where to go
they go to my website daryldavis.com
d-a-r-o-y-l davis.com and there they can
find my schedule my performance schedule
as well as my um
my speaking schedule or uh or
appearances on media you're going to
write another book
i'm updating the old book clandestine
relationships uh because i said the book
came out in the late 90s
and many things have happened since then
uh we have we've had a black president
we've had an increase in immigration
both legal and illegal and all of that
has has uh fueled
you know the the white right of that
mentality so i want to update the book
talk about people who are in there some
have passed some are still around
update people on that as well as tell
new stories of all the publicity you've
had over the years which
one got you the most visibility and the
most reaction
you know that's really hard to say
because i've had a lot a lot of great
ones
and the and there's some that are still
in the tan
uh for example um there's a natgeo thing
that's going to be showing
pretty soon with morgan freeman that uh
who interviewed me
and that's sure to generate a lot of uh
publicity um some on cnn and i'm sure uh
c-span with brian lamb would generate a
lot of publicity anyway daryl davis
we're out of time and we're going to
leave this enter just by showing 30
seconds of you
playing the 88s okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
if you enjoyed this week's q a interview
with daryl davis here are some other
programs you might like